let's talk about uh breaking news in
yuba
county uh this is a really fun role for
you i can tell you're having fun
with this role uh first of all you get
to wear
this incredible wig this amazing wig
my career would be so different if i had
this wig
stuck with this it's fantastic um
and and you get to play this character
who really let's
let's let's to just i don't know let it
all hang out there like there's a scene
where you destroy stuff in a mall
you absolutely just you you destroy a
bunch of things
and looking at you i can tell wand is
having fun
oh my god it was the best it was a
jewelry store
and we were you know falling off a heist
so smashed through the
through the mall through the glass and
everything ripped the
door off of the jewelry store with our
uh tow truck
right and just go in and just start
smashing stuff
smashing and grabbing it was the best
you know the prop guy had to run a
couple times to tell me no no no not
that case
they finished that case you got carried
away a little bit yeah that carried away
a little bit but i mean
it was i mean i i never felt that before
i mean you know
just to run in destroy stuff and and
with
not being held responsible or no
repercussions i'm like
it's like a little taste of what it's
like to be white
well and then you go home and you order
chilean sea bass
you don't even leave the house well we
have
a clip here and this is really fun this
is a fun scene where
um you're holding aquafina
prisoner and uh you've got a gun on her
and i've never been in a movie as an
actor but i've always thought
it must be fun i'm not a gun person i
don't own a gun
but it must be fun as a kid you know i
ran around with a cap gun it must be fun
to have a gun in a scene you know when
you know that no one's going to get hurt
and it it feels like
this is this is you having more fun in
with this character
oh yes all right let's take a look at
this uh
this clip from breaking news in yuba
county
now we don't want to hurt you well
you're gonna die tonight you're gonna
die tonight you're gonna die now
nobody's dying tonight just just
hey yeah yeah yeah it's gonna call the
boss make an even exchange
so everybody just chill out yeah yeah
chill out oh oh i'll chew you
out you're not gonna do [ __ ] old lady
[Music]
oh i'm gonna rip your door this time
it's gonna be your face
god damn it i gotta go janelle i gotta
go
janelle's in labor would you mind if i
held on to this yes i do mine you know
what you are right this belongs to you
this is yours
issue you don't shoot her whole air off
just her earlobe
just her earlobe just your little cuz
i'm not really that good at it
and i didn't even want to shoot her at
the it kind of just went off
yeah yeah that's right so it's it's okay
too if you're going to lose a part of
your body just earlobe i think
kind of acceptable you know um like a
piercing
yes exactly you did her which is a favor
in my opinion she should have paid you